so we're starting to kind of wrap up
various partial recounts and vote audits
from around the country
one came in from wisconsin and it's
absolutely hilarious
in wisconsin the trump campaign paid
about three million dollars
for a partial recount now remember that
in wisconsin the margin of victory for
joe biden was about 20 000 votes
and the outcome of the recount was that
joe biden gained 87 votes
in total from doing this partial recount
so statistically
it changes nothing biden was winning
before and biden is still winning
87 votes when the margin is 20 000
doesn't really do anything one way or
the other
but consider that donald trump's
campaign
paid three million dollars for this
partial recount
three million dollars to find 87 votes
for joe biden
that's 34 000 per vote
that the trump campaign paid uh well
actually
it would be trump's followers who
donated money
for the recounts they paid 34 000
per vote for joe biden in the end
now of course the trump campaign and
trump himself
already have an explanation as to why
the recounts aren't helping trump
and it becomes part of the conspiracy
theory it's almost evil genius if it
weren't so stupid and predictable
which is listen if you recount all of
the invalid votes
all of the illegal votes all of the
fraudulent votes
then of course you're going to get the
same results if they counted invalid
votes once
and then they recount them you're going
to get the same result
which now brings us to if they knew this
why did they pay for a recount and there
are two reasons number one is
optics and number two is they raised
money for recounts half of which was
used to pay off trump's campaign debt
remember
the fundraising emails that started
going out right after the election
saying
donate to stop the count or to start it
or to recount or to file
whatever the fine print was 50
of what you donate 50 cents on every
dollar
will go to paying off existing debt
that trump's campaign has so you raise 6
million
you pay 3 million for the wisconsin
partial recount
and you put 3 million towards your
campaign debt and meanwhile you insist
i'm
fighting joe biden's cheating by doing
this it's like the perfect final scam
actually against donald trump supporters
and this goes to something else that's
very important
the right doesn't really seem to
understand what voter fraud
is or in other words right wingers seem
to think that elections could be stolen
with actual voter fraud things like
people voting twice dead people voting
filling out fake absentee ballots and
sending them in that type of thing
so then they do a recount and the right
wingers are wondering wait a second how
it didn't change the results the problem
is that the real way you steal an
election
this isn't news to many of you i know
you don't steal an election with voter
fraud
you steal elections with election fraud
that means
gerrymandering in the first place that
at the congressional district level
removing mail sorting machines at the
post offices to slow down mail delivery
to try to get mail-in ballots to miss
the postmark date when you know that
it is overwhelmingly biden voters that
will vote by mail
rather than trump voters you steal an
election by organizing
voter purges of registered voters using
algorithms that would more likely hit
democratic voters than republican voters
you do it by
closing polling places in democratic
leaning areas and
sowing misinformation about where and
when
you're supposed to vote in those same
areas none of that stuff shows up in a
recount
now fortunately all of those methods
failed
to steal the election from joe biden but
think about the entire trajectory
here before the election it was trump's
going to win in a landslide you had
these hot take right-wing youtubers
saying
trump could get 400 electoral votes
trump landslide inevitable
all that stuff biden wins and so they
say oh it was stolen
you have to count the votes in some
places stop counting the votes in other
places remember that in the 96 hours
after the election you had protests
going on
at the same time saying stop counting
votes and start counting votes
then they say well do a recount oh but
the recounts change
nothing because they recounted the
illegal votes so then let's
file lawsuits which they do but then
when the judges actually ask trump's
lawyers
are you alleging voter fraud here in
court they say no we're not alleging
that
because they know they don't actually
have evidence of that fraud so
now they are on to the recounts
themselves are
bogus instead we need audits of each
vote
and we need state legislatures to send
republican electors
even if the state appears to have been
won by joe biden
that's where we are now that's how far
we've come in nearly the month since the
election
this will have some trajectory to
december 14th when the electors vote
and then they'll come up with something
new that will get us to january 20th
what it will be
i don't yet know but we'll continue
covering it
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
also follow me on instagram for very
boring pictures of my thanksgiving i'm
david
pakman on instagram one of our sponsors
today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste
amazing and magic spoon now lets you
create your own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own custom
variety box today make sure to use promo
code pacman to get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video